Here's a good one.
The United States has 331 million people in
it.
And Donald Trump claims that his decisions
on Corona virus have saved possibly billions
of people who otherwise would have died.
It makes as much sense to me as it makes to
you, I think.
Let's take a look at the video.
Sixty thousand or so, that's a lot of people.
But that's one hundred thousand was the minimum
we thought that we could get to.
And we will be lower than that number, anywhere
from 100 to 220000 people.
But I really believe it could have been millions
of people had we not done what we did.
We made a lot of good decisions.
But one of those things.
Go ahead.
It could have been billions of people.
Had we not done what we did.
Billions of people.
Only three hundred and thirty one million
live in the United States.
If Trump is claiming that shutting down flights
from China in early February saved billions
of people.
I just don't understand the mathematics of
it.
But let's pretend for a second to take it
seriously.
World's population believed to be just shy
of seven point eight billion right now, $7.8
billion people on planet Earth in the completely
unreasonable and cartoonish worst case where
not a single country did anything.
No, but he did suppression.
Nobody did.
Mitigation and corona virus spread globaly.
Worst case, about 7 billion people get it.
You would never have everyone get infected.
That's not how viruses work.
But imagine that of the seven point eight
billion people on earth, 7 billion get infect.
Maybe 40 million people would die.
There'd be about point six percent if you
went crazy and you say, let's double that,
80 million people would die.
Again, these are completely irrelevant numbers
because it assumes no country does anything
at all.
Even if you do that, it is ridiculous for
Trump to be talking about saving billions
of people.
And Trump says that merely stopping flights
from China could have saved a billion or billions
of people.
How do you save billions when your country
has three hundred and thirty one million people
in it?
I had this hilarious idea, which obviously
is not what Trump meant, but this is the type
of stuff I think about based on.
So at some point the sun is going to grow
and engulf planet Earth and planet Earth will
no longer be habitable for the homo sapiens.
Maybe we've moved on to some other solar system.
We don't know.
But OK, forget about that for a second.
Imagine that you save 50000 people today and
you calculate how many progeny are they likely
to have?
How many kids?
How many offspring will those 50000 people
have?
And then how many offspring will those kids
And then how many out?
Right.
And you go until the sun engulfs the earth.
Is it possible in that way Trump's actions
compared to doing nothing may have saved billions
of people?
I wonder what the number would actually be.
And again, it doesn't matter because what
Trump saying makes no sense.
But that's a little little bit of a peek behind
the curtain as to where my mind goes when
I read this type of stuff.
Of course, Donald Trump is not capable of
that type of thought.
It's not what he meant, but it crossed my
mind.
Trump now saying billions, billions are.
Are the numbers of people saved by his actions
on Corona virus?
You can't make this stuff up, folks.